there's a book just on your shoulder
that's carefully replace that can you
pick the booklet and tell me about it
right great book you should buy the
newer version of this up sorry brief
commercial announcement um yeah sure um
I think I mentioned at some point in our
conversation the fact that the people
working on multics well multics was sort
of the second version of time-sharing
that was done at MIT with collaboration
of Bell Labs and General Electric very
big system for providing in effect a
computing utility for programmers
multics was actually being written in
high-level languages they started with
pl one which was not a good choice and
then they moved to BCPL a language which
was developed in fact by Martin Richards
of Cambridge the people doing that who
are at Bell Labs in particular ken
Thompson and Dennis Ritchie had gotten
used to the idea that you could write
really interesting operating system
kinds of software and tools that
supported it in high level languages you
weren't writing assembly language and so
when they started working on UNIX this
very small stripped-down version that
was done at Bell Labs
they were at the same time exploring the
use of high-level languages and there
were a variety of these there was a
language called B which was the first
attempt it was done by Ken Thompson a
very simple language and I suppose you
could say it was sort of like a stripped
down version of BCPL
you know kind of a weak naming
convention there and so you could do
interesting things with B but it wasn't
quite powerful enough and in particular
it was an interpreter not a compiler and
that meant it didn't generate machine
code for the particular machine it was
running on it was just a program that
interpreted what it was trying to say so
MIT ran relatively slowly the other
thing is that the language did not
support the architecture of newer
machines that were showing up in
particular the pdp-11
newer machines instead of having
everything in the machine
be a single-sized of in effect integer
let's say 16 bits or something like that
they had different sizes that were the
machine would efficiently and naturally
manipulate 8-bit 16-bit maybe 32-bit the
language B didn't reflect that and so
Dennis Ritchie undertook to design what
amounted to a version of B that was
richer and had mechanisms in the
language to say this is an 8 bit
quantity this is a 16 bit quantity
basically the care and int types that
you see in the early versions of C and
so he wrote a compiler for that and then
with the compiler in hand they started
to rewrite the operating system itself
in C and this took a while something in
the order of six months to get that
working and at that point then you've
got the operating system of course all
kinds of other critical core software
written in a high-level language rather
than in assembly language and that's
important for all kinds of reasons one
it means that it's just a lot easier for
lots of people to see what the code does
you need so much expertise because it's
in the high-level language and the other
thing is that it's portable in the sense
that if somebody makes AC compiler for a
different kind of machine different
architecture then you can recompile
whatever your program is where that new
architecture and in that way you can
move your program to a different machine
now this has always been the advantage
of high level languages but now you
could do it for the operating system and
that meant that UNIX the operating
system no longer was only pdp-11 but
could run on a variety of other machines
as well I think the concepts of having a
high-level language I get you can boil
it down to hex is machine code that
right tells the processes to do stuff
right and if you have a different
compiler for a different
it just changes what those hex codes
it's correct that's exactly right so so
it should be really simple to understand
right an OS in a whole other language
but is it a bit like making a sharper
tool and using that sharper tool to make
a sharper - yeah right I think in fact
and and the complication is in building
and writing an operating system and a
high-level language and translating it
into let's say multiple different
architectures is there's a lot of detail
to get right there and there are some
things which the high-level language
just doesn't support so you need a
little tiny bit of assembly language
assist for any given operating system
the one is more like the conceptual
problem that you were explaining well is
how does the compiler itself get started
because of course the C compiler in C
and so there's the how do you get it
started and your idea of the sharper
tool making yet a sharper tool and so on
is metaphorically the right idea because
what you do is you say I wrote some code
in C on paper
let me mechanically translate that into
something that will process a bit more
of C code and then bootstrap myself up
from that so it's a bootstrapping
process and I've never done it so I take
me with a grain of salt on that but
that's the basic idea
ok so tell me about is proud of this
come about
so I'm looking I think that's really the
issue that's the first edition yes yes
this one isn't doctrine oh dear oh dear
this however is the 24th printing so
professor time for the old zero ok so I
will autograph it um how did the book
come about um somewhere early on in this
process of people building interesting
languages I got intrigued by the idea of
how do you explain those languages to
other people and so I wrote tutorial
documents I wrote a tutorial document on
B so that people could learn B because
ken Thompson and to a lesser degree
Dennis didn't write tremendous amount of
document
tation let's say it was spare and there
was not much tutorial stuff so I wrote a
tutorial document on B that was useful
when C came along then I wrote a
tutorial document on C and at some point
I had already written I guess a couple
of books at that point and it seemed
like the market the market that there
might be a market for a C book and so I
twisted Denis Ritchie's arm into writing
the book with me and that is the
smartest thing I ever did in my whole
life no ambiguity yeah so we took my
tutorial document as kind of a piece of
it we took his reference manual which is
a really excellent reference manual as a
big piece of it took that verbatim and
then we filled in material in the middle
to explain the various parts of the
language at more length and we published
that we wrote it in 1977 published at
the beginning of 78 and of course it was
done with all of the document
preparation tools that we had been
working on over the years and so it had
mathematical expressions in it using eqn
it had tables some things like operators
using Michael asks TBL program it the
first edition predates picked the
picture of drawing language but the
second edition has picked pictures and
so on so is this incestuous or is this
building on what other people have done
I don't know but but that's how it came
about and I remember talking to the
editor this was published by prentice
hall with Karl Karl strim aw the editor
there and I remember a discussion with
him about how many copies do you think
this will sell and no idea well maybe
five thousand so so it's done better
than that just just as well
it was every night because he was being
this nice strong there was there was a
language Steve Johnson who was all part
of this the creator of yak of Steve
Johnson spent a sabbatical at the
University of Waterloo in Ontario and he
came back with a leg I don't worry
somebody else had done it a language
there called a but it was spelled eh a
bit of Canadian humor I guess